moments ago tj jefferson apologized uh
to adam ray without him being out here
because he walked past him in a hallway
going to the bathroom
and
didn't say hello didn't recognize that
it was him and now adam ray has shown up
and he couldn't be more conspicuously
dressed
i mean honestly like what do you think
like a mariner
supersonics fan was just a storm
kamikaze shoe wearing guy was just
waiting to drop a deuce after tj
oh yeah i just i came all the way out
here to use the bathroom to sit on the
same seat that you sit on
honestly like i even said have fun in
there
when he walked in
i was facing
facing the lobby and then i said hey
have a good time man and he didn't he
just did one of those
whatever people say have a good time all
the time to me when i go in the bathroom
because i'm dj and i do a great tom
brokaw was that you
kind of what was that chris parnell
that's right
[Laughter]
you know i don't see too many people
walking around here these days and just
lingering and loitering
so if it's not obvious um yes i was born
in lake forest park washington i could
never tell
so look i'm rocking the uh the goat sue
bird yeah okay oh gosh she's an actual
tank top actually actual cheers yeah by
the way if i make pictures like what
would you really
put your shirt on yeah and i got the
mitch haniger yeah they got mitch right
nice the uh soon-to-be 2022 major league
baseball most valuable player mitch
haniger or future new york yankee yeah
rich
we're not even welcoming 90 seconds into
this interview i mean josh jonathan's
getting up there let's just go down the
line let's see tino martinez luis soho
uh jeff nelson i mean dude when it rains
jeff nelson
hey we gave you jay bunner so let's be
you did and i'll take that that was a
big one oh my god we gave jake johnson
played for the yankees too right yeah i
mean but randy was more later yeah
you know a quick randy johnson story i
met randy at the x games because he's
now a photographer yes i've heard yes
and uh and i went to usc and randy went
to usc i thought and i was uh
you know a die hard ems fan growing up
while he was there used to take the bus
with my buddies from albertsons all the
way down to the kingdome make signs
right we've when rob ducey was playing
we made a sign that said getting ducey
with it just to get on the job
and it worked
i mean
we made signs for the guys that everyone
forgot about and um and so randy i see
him at the x games and i'm thinking usc
spent a lot of money and emotional wear
and tear supporting the big unit over
the years um
you know even uh you just had nolan ryan
on my my mom dated a guy who brought me
to nolan ryan's last game at the
kingdome uh which was the first time i
met randy johnson but thank god that
relationship didn't work out because
that guy tried to shoot uh
hoops with me but he called him basket
shots and i was like mom if this is any
indication of how things are going to go
in the bedroom please get out now uh
thank god you met my stepdad george i
just celebrated 20 years mom george i
love you um so i meet randy get shots
basket shots you mind if i shoot some
basket shots with you i was like i don't
want you anywhere near my mother with
your hand or your mouth because if you
call shooting hoops basket shots who
knows what you're going to do to her
adam right here on the right side
so anyway so i meet randy and i go hey
man you might if i get a quick pick like
i just try to give a quick anytime you
meet somebody
uh you know even when i um when i met
you at the nba awards i try you know you
wanna you don't wanna fan out too hard
but you wanna show your gratitude your
appreciation and but i think people also
appreciate it you know i um just met al
michaels two weeks ago at a king's game
and i try to make a quick joke anytime i
meet someone like that and i go out big
fan of go we actually matched on uh
tinder uh two weeks ago and then i
started laughing and i go no i'm just
kidding i go to shake his um
his brother's hand and uh and al doesn't
let go of my hand and then pulls me back
in and goes no no we did
and michael is smart
ladies and gentlemen now michael is
committing to the tinder joke
are you kidding me wow he was friends
with my um make this up i can't make it
up so so randy i go can i get a quick
pick uh randy you just
you know and then he just goes i don't
think so man i don't know what you're
going to do with it
to which i go
what and he goes i don't know what
you're gonna do with my picture i go
with all due respect mr johnson mr unit
i am yes and by the way you know i'm uh
six one he's you know almost seven feet
so i'm truly face to face with the big
unit yes and uh
and i go do you mind uh explaining what
do you mean by that and he goes a lot of
people out there you know i don't take
pictures of me and then they photoshop
them on like bodies of dragons and
centaurs
i'm not making this uh energizing what
is his who the hell is he
i mean what the heck to which i then say
randy johnson i go
look at me in the eyes man i know i'm a
33 year old grown adult man you really
think i'm going to take a picture you
and spend the time that it takes to find
a decent dragon that's going to fit
because i'm not going to do a piss poor
photoshop just not i'm going to perform
ahead and i'm a professional
i'm going to make sure that your main
matches the length and girth of the
dragon's body i can't believe i'm
actually saying this to you anyway i
guess i'll get on the photo he goes i'll
sign your hat if you want and i go
yeah that'd be great
wow so we signed my hat wow that being
said you know like hey
headline is you're not getting your
picture taken with randy johnson no
selfies
he takes pictures but won't uh obviously
but look i mean
i don't know how tough is it to uh to
step in and uh make a kid's dream come
true even if that kid is 33. but i
digress happy to be here happy to be
from seattle can i do can i just where's
my i might cry in front of rich eyes and
cam before you start can i just before
before we do that let me kind of like
introduce you
great to be here you know what i mean
like i don't think i've given you a
proper hello i'm absolutely like
successful certainly since our radio
audience
just surfed in the middle of all that
randy johnson
centaur conversation
adam ray is here on the rich eisen show
um the only people talented enough to
play vince mcmahon
uh ron ziegler by the way i know the
name coming up
hey
by the way what sports hosts know the
name of president nixon's uh press
secretary off the top of his head you
and maybe dave wyman okay um i don't
know who that is uh and jay leno you
play jay leno on the new pam and tommy
hit show that's going on right now on
hulu yeah uh and you're in young rock as
vince mcmahon i mean you are uh you're
versatile you're like yeah you're the
jack of all trades and hopefully in 30
years i will play meryl streep in the
merrell streep story
okay called uh
str uh street step up to the streets
there you go wow i panicked for a minute
wasn't gonna happen
i don't know if he stopped the landing
but
but it was definitely
definitely wobbling on that balance beam
through that gag by the way somewhere
randy johnson watching going and that's
why i didn't take the picture
and uh your stand-up date's coming up uh
this very weekend in batavia illinois at
the comedy vault in dallas texas at the
deep ellum festival on the first of
april okay so now what do you have there
so um is this my uh
that is your camera uh straight ahead
all right you've got uh what you're
holding oh russell wilson seahawks i
will remember you
oh my gosh will you remember me probably
not cause i hit you up on facebook once
he didn't get back to me but it's all
good gets it busy
hopefully drew luck
will give a [ __ ]
and we'll go back
by the way uh sarah mclaughlin is uh
doing the same thing as randy johnson
she'll never take a picture with you and
by the way give kudos to mike hoskins
who used dissolve shots
to go back and forth management cameras
that only was just hyping the drama was
there a slow zoom melodrama there was no
slumber that's okay i mean it's just i
mean we're not there we're still we're
still working there yet we're not there
yet we're working our way towards zooms
uh you guys are crushing it this i uh
you're on the rich eisen show yeah you
guys are just uh i'm just crushing the
game i'm sorry about it this is um
that's great i mean look i looked uh my
fiance hey babe she goes are you gonna
bring your wrestle wilson jersey i go
yeah and then bring up my parents
divorce geez you're full of great ideas
this morning babe no she goes uh
she goes
she goes bring it and and do a little
bit and uh i mean it is crazy let me
just jeffrey dean morgan uh yes he was
on the show last week you've done uh a
great service by the way to a lot of uh
you know whether it's joel mchale rayne
wilson uh you really show a lot of love
to the seattle sports boys i try my best
they're passionate the best and um very
passionate uh his take was fair you know
it was shocking i remember my fiance
even took a video i should have brought
it but he probably wouldn't have been
able to play with all the um choice
words but yes but she captured when i
saw it in real time
and it was
i think you have loyalty in sports is
such a tricky i'm sure you've you know
at great length just discussed it when
players leave and and how certain guys
that stay a whole career the jeters of
the world are so few and far between
right even griffey who you know we had
had done so much for the city that when
he left to cincinnati the family reasons
were such a uh driving um you know uh
contribution to that whole experience
that
we kind of just were like hey man best
of luck even though it was so sad
um
sean can't believe it my man uh
that sucked because there was contract
stuff at play
you know management didn't really handle
that the best as they could
signed jim mcelveen instead of kemp
which hey looking back
what a move
they're making a 30 for 30 on that on
jim mcelveen no i'm just kidding wow i'm
so gullible can we go jimmy mcveigh
have been mentioned on the show today
right
judd apatow was in that chair about an
hour ago could have been an hour ago at
this very moment and dropped a glenn
gondrazek uh message
it's very very very long time i don't
mean to interrupt no no you're fine it's
um it's just a it's a tough time because
of the uncertainty but it's exciting
because of the uncertainty well it's
also um you know we were talking about
it on this program as it was happening
is the the you were that's right i was
texting brockman he was like wrong right
now talking about i was like i don't i
can't afford you know peacock you know
and uh yeah it's free but
um so no the the
that russ goes and then
as you're
absorbing
that yeah even though you kind of had a
year plus heads up it was coming yes
that it now had finally happened at a
time when you thought you might have
been in the clear for another year with
them
as you're absorbing that
bobby wagner getting cut was the coup de
gras like that's the proverbial cherry
on top yeah it was kind of that made you
just question whether life was what you
thought it would be outside of football
like that's one of those sports moments
that makes you wonder if the entire
foundations of your life like you had to
call your loved ones to see if they're
okay type sports moment yeah you're i
mean some people who don't understand
sports are like these guys are dramatic
but no that's exactly it
[Laughter]
you're nailing it on the head i mean
russ you're exactly right you had a
little it's like when they told you
crystal clear pepsi was going to be
discontinued you go we all knew it was
coming right and also what was it doing
here in the first place but
russ the talk of russ was just too much
yes and you know uh my boy bob stellen
host the afternoon show in seattle i
listened to uh them every day and it was
it was almost
overwhelming with how much it was uh
being discussed and to a point to where
and i remember he was even uh texting
with brockwood about i was like
i feel like it's doing more damage with
how much it's getting played right where
i was like but that was me also probably
in denial and not wanting to believe the
truth to it which you could understand
but i was like it's getting talked about
so much that eventually something's
going to happen because uh because it
won't be dropped but also on the flip
side i think he uh there was truth to
where there's what is it where there's
fire there's a smoke this one blizzard
yeah there's if there's an oreo cookie
blizzard there's a there's a there's a
theory okay
there's
there's some sort of a saying yes yeah
well no look i i i i there's an open
urinal there's tj waiting to make it
weird is that the same yeah yes okay yes
so that's the old saw
so look it bobby getting cut was a
bummer and
and with no heads up didn't he find out
he said that the team didn't he said he
found out through media reports which is
nutty uh i mean but i guess when you fly
without an agent right there look at you
guys right crazy part oh see that just
man it's things he was he's a you know
first ballot and ring of honor and a guy
that
like russ i mean truly that's the end of
the
that era of sales that was it the legion
of boom error came to a close that day
correct that is correct wow where the
you know the general manager and the
coach are the only and the 12s are the
only ones that remain you know so are
you saying um adam ray that you told
denver broncos fans
that their team in their big acquisition
just acquired the crystal clear pepsi of
quarterbacks is that what you're telling
me right now is that what i said
i mean i
uh edibles and sometimes those carry
into the next morning and sometimes i
say things that i don't
mean what does that mean bobby wagner i
mean is he the classic
feels good tastes good what is that the
great fanta i don't know that's no
that's miller i don't know
palmer crystal clear pepsi corona
premier let's see what was it doing here
at all
i mean look i do take offense and i
think all i want to get you guys quick
take on this yes when you have a player
that you revere so much like that and i
actually watched russ's denver uh press
conference spectacular it was i got real
actually choked up because what i think
is great and my white rapper
brother-in-law dirty who is not a rust
fan i'll say that one more time my white
rapper brother-in-law dirty
um yes
uh is a big hawks fan but not a rust fan
and has forever been like we can do
better this is not he doesn't fit in our
system
it's a hot take find out and i'm like oh
thank god you're a great dad to my
nephew and he says
and i mean what's what's worse uh
shooting a basketball buckets or what do
we call that basketball shots
basketball
what's worse in terms of
family involved people
having takes calling hoops basket shots
i'm a huge hawks fan
this last eight years has been
generationally unbelievable yes but i
don't buy the guy who's the trigger man
who was dropped in our lap
you know
tell him to talk to a jet fan i'll talk
to your brother-in-law
hey
get a clue just the fact that by the way
he loves you just the fact that you said
his name on tv he might be reaching for
uh some lubriderm at this moment but so
okay
i do think that sorry dirty what i mean
to be so aggressive he uh
russ's press conference he's think about
any other
not even a football player but
quarterback when russ immediately talks
about all the um
impacts that his presence is going to
have not just football but
he at one point he goes we're going to
win some games he goes but we're going
to change some lives he goes i'm looking
to impact the community and he said that
almost out of the gate and i go
i just always thought he was a um
says what he means guy and look you can
argue that the you know weird selfies on
the beach and the you know mr unlimited
you know and all that is extra that
isn't necessary but i'm like i don't
know man
the guy spends a lot on his body you
know uh you know we spend almost about
the same amount you know which is
odd and um
that it doesn't uh okay you guys hope we
can add it in some more laughter though
yeah that's fine no you're on your own
summer man
just tell them
just talk just
how many of you have that up though
forever a couple months now i know about
a year yeah we got it up here incredible
is he is that your guy teach i like him
he's many tj's got many guys many teams
many guys he's just a man of many uh
facets including
walking past an absurdly dressed
seahawks fan is here and is actually
famous for what he does and is appearing
on the show because he is such and two
shoes that i've watched
all right so um let me get your plugs in
before we uh we send you on your good uh
are we almost done yeah man
i will say this real quick i went to
spring training two days ago have you
been to spring training ever probably
right yes
the best and uh the mariners look good
jerry depotto shout out general manager
building the squad okay um jerry depotto
has the energy of the guy behind frank
thomas and the eugenics commercial that
goes trust me it works and you know what
i love that because that's a guy you
trust
if you say that line with conviction you
go that guy's going to build a world
series championship organization well
you know what i see that commercial and
i'm struck by the realism you know i i
just i look at this and i'm like this
looks real can i be honest i feel like i
did i honestly i sit there i'm like did
this happen you know like that's the way
i have you guys ever done doug foodie
and frank thomas hang out oh yeah
weird combo you were so good in those
sportscenter commercials i there's got
to be a way to get you into one of these
new genics ads no
and i'm not saying you need it because i
feel like everything's clicking and
taking all i got to do is ask all you
gotta do is ask i feel like frank you
just have a your your delivery even at
the end of the youtube videos for all of
the um uh shows where you go hey you
made it to the end thanks for that
your delivery is just you know what adam
i i appreciate that yes you know i guess
what i'm saying is we need to get your
agent a little bit more get you into
some he's watching get to the dan
patrick cameo system yeah let's go let's
go you know what that's what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna be there's we got one
jewish adam taking care of patrick the
next one
just gonna keep stacking the chips and
then you're going to pop up in
everything i do even dirty's music
videos
music videos by the way
that would be amazing great fantasy
he will fly down here tonight does dirk
have a mix cloud link or something that
should show you dirty just youtube man i
give this kid so much press dirty type
in youtube dirty there's got to be only
one how does one spell dirty d-i-r-t-a-y
oh
when i first met him he was like call me
dirty i was like i'm not gonna do that
i'll call you tim no he's great go
outside make some basket shots
young rock on nbc tuesdays at eight
eastern the uh gaslit uh premieres on
april 24th i mean uh this looks great
julia roberts sean pence shea wiggum
who's been on this program oh great i
love him yeah it's from watergate uh
it's about watergate martha mitchell who
was uh
crazy the story's boxing she was taking
basket shots back in the day
i can't get that out of my head
pam and tommy you play jay leno that's
available on hulu about last night
podcast and also uh how could people
find out more about your stand up today
stand updates at adamaraycomi.com uh and
please check out my podcast about last
night i've had on sandra bullock bill
bird jason droulo travis kelsey gary
payton sean kemp sue bird uh dana carvey
hopefully rich eisen at some point you
just asked
but it's great
my stand-up comedy days did you do yeah
in college not so i don't know why i
said that with so much surprise dad no
it's all right
it's all right i just i like surprising
people let me ask you this why did you
uh dip out uh because i realized i
wasn't cut out for it gotcha the grind
of it oh big time
a different grind was waiting for you
well a different grind was waiting for
me with less seemingly very miserable
people around me
[Laughter]
very i'm saying you're part of that but
yeah i saw i saw i saw the tragedy part
as well yeah yeah it gets uh it gets um
interesting
it gets low but that's why thank god for
sports you know adam raycomedy on
twitter and instagram um come on back
anytime thanks for having me tj we'll
get past it
how it starts and how it ends our story
is just getting started that's right
we'll never we'll never walk by each
other in the hallway again
well not with that attitude
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here